there is no escaping the agony in beirut
hospitals already inundated with victims
of the explosion
are now filling with protesters injured
by the security forces
firas hamden told me he was out on the
streets last saturday
and whilst filming this facebook live
was almost killed
you can see the explosion in the center
of the crowd
a metal pellet from what it's thought
was a grenade pierced his heart
i walked for two meters and i
shut down as i collapsed on the earth
and
the other colleague i'll bring me
to him i am glad to be
alive it pierced all the chest walls the
heart from side to side and it looked
into the posterior
posterior wall of the heart firas
underwent emergency surgery
and amazingly he'll make a full recovery
dr karim neme who's been treating him
says he's seen more than 50 patients
wounded in the protests
many of the injuries are too graphic to
show
all the injuries were on the upper upper
part of the body
face shots neck shots chest injuries
all all of these could kill the patients
could kill the protesters
lebanon's anti-government protests
erupted after the explosion at the port
the human rights activists and doctors
claimed the methods deployed here by the
security services
are in breach of international law
[Music]
rabby barakat bears the scars from the
tear gas canister
it appeared to have been fired directly
at his face
he's come back to the place where it
happened to tell us
what he remembers and i had no idea
whether this was live ammunition rubber
bullet
or um a tear gas bomb i would really
like to
know who uh gave the order to shoot
these
tear gas bombs straight
straight to our heads and i would really
like to
to look him in the eye
and tell him was this really necessary
human rights watch observed these
protests first
hand it's conducted its own
investigation
the evidence is overwhelming security
forces
seem to have fired live ammunition at
protesters they seem to have fired
rubber bullets including a protesters
faces which is prohibited by
international law
the lebanese authorities are denying
they used excessive force
or rubber bullets but in this country
hollowed out by years of corruption
where people have no faith in the
government it's a response that's
unlikely to be believed
alex rossi sky news beirut